[APPLAUSE]
ERIC WOERNER: So
that picture of me
that was up there
before this started
was back in 2015, when I
was lucky enough to present
at the first Dart summit.
As you can see, there's not the
gray hair, up in that picture.
That is not a direct reflection
from working on AngularDart.
It's exactly the
opposite, actually.
So I'm Eric Woerner.
I work at Trustwave on
the portal infrastructure,
and today, we're going to talk
about the power of AngularDart,
and how we built
out our Customer
Portal taking advantage of it.
So let's go over a little bit,
at the beginning, of what we're
going to cover.
So first, we'll talk about
building out a large scale
portal, and what that means for
Trustwave portal development--
to kind of set the landscape,
and the view that we're
looking at.
And then we'll look into
what we were looking
for when we went into
a new UI initiative
to get off of our legacy
technology we were using.
Then we'll look at what did
we consider at that time, when
we were going down this
endeavor-- what was out there,
what was in the
landscape, before we
made the wise choice of
picking Dart and AngularDart.
And then we'll jump into
what we've taken advantage
with in Dart, as
far as building out
a base component for our
teams to use to develop with.
Taking advantage of routing
and deferred loading,
to lazy-load our portal
as it goes through,
as the customer goes
through our portal.
Taking advantage
of UI components
and building those out
for our teams to use.
And then, also, the tools that
we have taken advantage of,
and why we chose
Dart to begin with.
So Trustwave portal development.
We have a large-scale
portal that we build,
that has about 15
distributed teams--
that is about 50-plus
developers that
are divided across these teams.
And they build about 35
different applications that
take advantage of 1,000-plus
Java services that we've built
on the back end, using Spring.
Some of those are part of
our portal infrastructure
that we build out,
but a lot of them
are from our product
service teams,
for the services that need
to support the views that are
built out for those products.
We have 40,000
unique global users
that log into our portal--
one portal-- on a daily basis.
So all this is brought together
from our team development that
takes place, and
we've got to make sure
that we bring it into one
build, and leverage whatever
technology we're using to build
out some sort of framework
that the teams can
take advantage of.
So we'll go back a little bit.
It was 2013.
We had a legacy portal
that was built off
of using flex with Flash.
And we all know what's happened
with Flash-- it's died.
It's dead.
The browsers have caught
up with what we could
take advantage of at that time.
It was a good choice, back
then, but the browsers
have caught up.
So we were looking
for what's next?
What are we going to go to?
So what were we looking
at at that time?
There was, you know,
the team development
we had to take advantage
of, but we also
had to look at new
requirements coming in.
So we wanted to make sure
that we could build out
a portal framework, and that
for our customer experience when
they came to our portal, they
had a quick initial startup
time.
We didn't want them
sitting there and waiting
for the download to take place.
We wanted it to pop
up quickly for them.
That means also we wanted
to lazy-load our portal.
The teams, as they
work on these views
that they're putting
together for their products,
we don't want it to
download all at once,
and have this big memory
footprint within the browser--
we want to incrementally
grow the portal
as the user goes through it.
We want it to be fast rendering
within our UI components,
so there's not a lot
of waiting for the user
as they click through.
And we want to take
advantage of something
that we called in the past "deep
linking"-- where we can send
URLs to our customers that
they can click on and go right
to the area within the portal,
so they don't have to log in
and dive in from there.
And also, that they could
bookmark these URLs,
to get back quickly to
the area that they wanted
to go to within our portal.
Then there's the
team development
that we discussed previously.
We have a unique look
and feel at Trustwave
that we go off of
for our portal.
So we want to make sure we have
a set of shared UI components
that the teams can
use, that are built
in a consistent manner
with the proper style--
so they don't have to worry
about that when they build out
their products.
This goes along with,
also, a base component
that they can leverage and use,
as well, that they can rely on,
that's going to
build in and bring
in services for
their base things,
like security and
locale information,
that they don't have to
worry about on their side,
so they can concentrate
on their product.
We wanted to have
quick dev cycles.
We want to have our developers
be able to make changes,
see it in the
browser right away,
and not have to wait
for some compile step
to take place before they can
see what their change was,
so we can deliver quicker.
A short learning curve was
something that was on our list,
as well.
We have-- a lot of our
developers are both,
you know, back end
developers, and then
we have purely UI developers.
But most of them work
full-stack development.
So we wanted to make
sure whatever technology
we picked was intuitive to them,
and there was a short learning
curve, so they could come up
to speed quickly, and start
building this out.
And then, of course,
testing involved in it.
The components we
build on our team
and the portal
infrastructure, we
want to make sure
we can test them,
so we supply out good
components for our teams to use.
And then you look into
the tools that need
to come with this, as well.
If we have this
team development,
we need to make sure that we
can have core sets of libraries,
and we can bring this all
into one build that goes out.
So we need the
dependency management
on top of it, a good
IDE integration,
and then be able to do
continuous integration
builds out to our test
areas with our dev ops team,
and the pod ops
teams to production.
So, back in 2013, when
we looked into this,
you can see there's just
a plethora of choices
out there that we
could pick from.
So, you know, most of these
are JavaScript frameworks.
And that, right off
the bat, kind of
made me sick to my
stomach a little bit,
when you look at
the team development
we were doing in trying
to bring this together.
And then, also, you know,
there was GWT at the time.
And we could have gone
backwards and went that way,
but we wanted to pick
a technology that
was going to stay in the front,
and keep up with the times,
and always increase, and
get better and better.
And something that we can
stay out of the spaghetti code
land of JavaScript, where
building that-- bringing that
into one build-in
going forward just
made me kind of
quiver, a little bit.
So say hello to Dart
and AngularDart.
So it's back in 2013, again.
I keep going back
in the time machine.
And we're sitting there,
and we say, hey, look--
the dart SDK is out here.
Let's check it out.
So what we started doing
is some prototyping,
and then we started doing
some brown bags internal
with our engineering teams.
And we were building
just some command line,
talking to web sockets,
and bringing it in.
This was even before the
package HTML was out there
for building any type of UI.
So what did we
discover at that point?
Well, we discovered that
this is a complete SDK
with a core set of
libraries and tools
that we could leverage for
building out our portal,
going forward.
It was very-- it supports
high-quality tools,
large scale, like I said.
And then extensive
libraries that
were out there, that
we could pick up
from other people
that are contributing
third-party libraries.
So this was something that,
coming from a background that
we have-- some Java developers--
or no matter what software
language you were coming from--
we were getting feedback
through the brown bags,
like, this is very
intuitive for me.
I can pick this up very quickly.
And it has everything that
I've leveraged in the past,
in other languages, and I
can take advantage of it.
And I don't have to play
around in the JavaScript land
on these things.
It has a great cross-compile
over to JavaScript.
It was like, oh, that's great.
Because we've got
to make sure that we
can support all the major
browsers that are out there.
And then the one that
really sold us, at the end,
is when the switch came in
Dart to go to Strong Mode.
We were already
building out Dart
to be very strongly-typed
for building
with the other
developers that were
used to this from the languages
they'd built in the past.
So when Dart made the decision
to go full Strong Mode,
it just hooked us even more as
we started going down the pipe,
and those announcements
kept going,
and it was evolving over.
So now that we'd picked the
Dart SDK, and we're like, OK,
this is what we're going to use,
we still needed a web framework
to go on top of it.
So we started looking into
Angular, all the way back
at Angular 1.0.
And that's the initial
prototype, and actually
the initial portal that we
were launching internal,
that we built off of.
So why did we like
Angular so much?
Well, this is just piggybacking
off of what Matan was talking
about earlier-- is that, based
off the templates and the event
bindings--
events and bindings.
The routing,
dependency injection--
everybody in our
company that's worked
on services on the back end, it
was all within Java and Spring.
So they understood dependency
injection, and the power of it.
And then Pipes.
And then Angular Components
was announced last year.
And it came out, and
it's like, great.
Now we have a core set of
libraries we can share.
So we've watched Angular
evolve from 1.0 to 2,
getting broke off to
being internal to Dart
and getting off the
JavaScript builds.
And we've seen over
time how it's increased.
Code size has shrunk.
Speed of download has
gotten better and better.
And we've seen the
improvements that we've
built out our portal.
So we're very happy, at this
point, the decision we've
made, because it's made us
very quick and up-to-speed
on where the browser
is going, and also
being able to leverage
using Dart and AngularDart
to meeting our requirements.
So Andrew is a developer
that's on my team,
on the portal
infrastructure side.
And he came to us from
a JavaScript background,
and a NET background.
And he was able to
pick it up, and come up
to speed very quickly.
He discovered that he's
not battling things
that were in JavaScript before,
but Dart, just coding it,
worked the way it was supposed
to work, out of the box.
So this is just proof that he
came in, he got up to speed--
he was delivering
components that
were production-ready in
about two to three weeks.
And our teams were
starting to use them.
So it's a very nice language,
that you can come up
to speed very quickly.
And then Keith is
on the other side.
And he's been at Trustwave
for years, all the way back
to our legacy portal.
And he comes from
a Java background.
And on the Java side, it's
the same type of experience.
It didn't matter what
software language background
you were coming from.
Picking up Dart was intuitive,
and quick to pick up,
and you can deliver quickly.
So now that we've decided
on Dart and AngularDart,
we also, during
this UI initiative
that we were going
off, we wanted
to rethink our portal design.
Our legacy portal was
built off of the concept
of each application was its
own module that would load in.
But we wanted to break
this down to our customer,
not by what products
they were provisioned to,
but more intuitive-looking
areas within our portal,
and that top blue area,
that they are accustomed
to across their products.
So this is just a small subset,
at the top of the blue area,
of, like, Home, Assets,
Findings, Support,
that you can find at the
top of our navigation.
Below there, depending
on what section you pick,
you would get a set of menus.
This is where a user is
provisioned to certain--
based off the products they
have, what menus they will get.
So our portal kind of grows
for them as they log in.
So they could just maybe have
Home and Assets, or Assets
and Findings, and the menus
that are underneath there.
From there, if the user
clicks on one of those menus,
this is where the team
development comes in--
that the product team has
built one of these elements,
and it loads within the
stage from that point.
So this is the vision
that we had going forward,
when we wanted to
build out this new UI,
and the approach that
we wanted to take.
So how did we use Dart
and AngularDart to achieve
this vision that we had?
Well, first thing
it came down to
was building a base component.
We needed to contract
with our development teams
that we knew, when this
component loaded in,
we knew how to interact with it.
Also, this base component
needed to make sure
that it took care of some of
the base lifecycle events,
and we can hook into
them for loading things
for the user-- such
as locale information,
because we're a global company,
or security information,
or properties information.
We didn't want to have each
one of these development
teams doing this on their own.
They should just
concentrate on the product
that they build out.
And this has always
been our vision
of how we build a
portal infrastructure.
So within this class
that we built out,
this base portal
component, you have--
it implements base
Angular lifecycle events.
With true inheritance that comes
with-- since the Angular 4 came
out with components--
now, teams don't
have to worry about implementing
these lifecycle events.
They can still
get hooks in them,
but we wanted to have this
in the base component,
so we can tie into them.
So you look on the ngOninit
override that we have--
this is where we load in
locale information that's
been specified by the
implementing component,
security information, and
properties information.
And then, based
off this component
I'll show on the
next slide, they
have hooks into when this
information is loaded.
So they can react to it
within their implemented view.
Also within here, we
have a component service
taking advantage of
dependency injection.
This allows us, on this
component service--
it binds multiple
services into it,
so then it's dependency-injected
into our base component
for things such as routing,
and other services we need
to call on our base component.
So now, we have this base
component ready to go.
The teams can implement
and go from there.
And they can rely
on knowing that they
have this base functionality
they can take advantage of.
So how does a team
implement this?
So now, the developer's
teams basically
extend off of the
base portal component.
This is an example from
the assets search component
that we have within our portal.
So this is a menu of a
component that would line up
under the area of assets.
And within here, we still
do the dependency injection
of the component service, so we
can get to the base component,
so it has a handle on it.
But then you look
at three overrides
that were within this class
of the implementation.
You have onLocaleLoaded,
onSecurityLoaded,
and onPropertiesLoaded.
So the one we're going
look at, specifically,
is the implementation
under SecurityLoaded.
So this function is going to be
called from the base component
once the security information
is loaded for this component.
So this team that's
developing this view
can rely on, at that point--
hey, I need to check
permission on a resource,
and whether they have
the execute permission
for the Search button.
The IsPermitted method comes
off the base component, as well,
so they don't have to be
looking through that cache
to find that out.
So now, the team
can rely on-- hey,
let me do that check for that
resource, tie it to a buoy,
and then I can tie it to
my backing HTML template
with binding, and that button
is going to be enabled, or not.
Now we have this base component.
We know how to
communicate with it.
It's got a contract within
our portal framework.
So now our teams can
build independently,
and know, when we go to the main
deployment, and it goes out,
that component is going
to work correctly.
But they built that out, now.
How do we go about loading
it into our portal?
And also, initially,
I was talking about,
well, we want to make sure that
we keep the initial download
time for our portal very quick,
and we want to lazy-load things
in.
Well, this is where we
take advantage of routing
and deferred loading
within our portal.
So the top URL, there, you see--
this goes into our
production environment.
And you have the
bolded assets first,
that ties to the top menu area.
So that means when
that route comes in,
whether they clicked on it or
whether there was a bookmark,
it's going to highlight
the blue assets area,
at the top, that
has been selected.
From there, we
need to know well,
what's the menu underneath that
area that we want to go to?
Well, it's the Search area
for the asset search--
that's where the bolded area
on the end of the URL is.
So, no matter how they
got to this destination,
it routed to this area
within the portal.
Now, the search is tied
to a specific element
name that's been developed
by one of our teams.
And that's how we determine,
at that point, wow-- ok,
we have this element.
We need to put
this on the stage.
But we want to make sure,
when we load that in,
that it's just not already
in the JavaScript file
that's initially downloaded-- we
want to make sure we load that
in at the point that the
customer or user wants
to access it.
So that's the point we
wanted to defer load it
into the elements stage.
So how do we do that?
So this comes with
deferred loading.
So the first thing you're
going to see, at the top,
is you're going to
import in your file
that the asset search
component is within.
But I'm not importing
the assets search file.
I'm importing the template
file, that's not there
until it goes through
the compile time step.
So this isn't here
during development time,
but it's there at runtime.
So we want to make sure
that the first comment
at the top of this file--
this is just basically
telling the IDE
and the Dart analyzer, hey--
ignore this.
I know it's not
here, at this point,
so don't give me a nice,
red squiggly underneath it.
Ignore it.
It's going to be
there at runtime.
But underneath
there, you don't just
import this as a
regular library.
We want to defer load this in.
So we want to make
sure that we're
telling the compiler that,
hey-- don't include this
in the main JavaScript file.
Create a part file that can
be loaded in during runtime,
when it needs to be accessed.
So that's where the
DeferredAs, and we name it off
as assets search view.
So now we have it
deferred, but now we
need to make sure-- how do we
load this in using Angular,
and make sure it shows up in
the UI when we go through?
Well, the next point
that we have in here
is, we have an app view child
annotation, that's basically
saying, I'm looking for
a marker in the back HTML
to a named element called Stage.
And I want to bring that in
as a view container reference,
and I'll call that Stage.
So now, I just have a hook on
an element in my backing HTML,
and this is where I'm going
to load my component next to,
at this point.
Next, I've got to make sure
that I have the component
loader from Angular
dependency-injected
with into my stage
component, here.
So I make sure that there is
dependency injection bringing
in the loader.
So now I have a
handle on the loader.
So now-- just real quick--
I should've said this
at the beginning.
This is really shrunk down, just
to show the relevant pieces.
There's other things that go on.
But I just shrunk
this down to what
we need to show
to have an example
of the deferred loading.
So the next step is
there is this Load View
component with the element.
So when the menu
is clicked on, I
know what the element name is.
And usually, there is a bigger
case, here-- switch case,
to determine which deferred
library I'm going to load in.
But I already know, here.
So I shrunk this down to
loading into asset search view.
So I need to do an
AsyncAwait at this point,
and Await for loading
in that library.
After I have a handle
on that library,
I need to init the
reflector, which
is going to tell Angular to
make sure that the component is
inited, so that I can get
a handle on the component
factory.
At the end of this statement, I
get a reference on asset search
view-- the asset
search component--
with the bolded
Ngfactory at the end.
I want to highlight that.
Because that's another
area that's not there
during development time, but
will be there during runtime.
So now you have the handle
on the component factory.
Its been deferred loaded.
I have a handle on it within
my backing Dart class.
But now I need to
call the loader,
and make sure its
instantiated within the UI.
So now I load next to
the stage component--
this component factory--
boom.
There-- you got it.
It's loaded in the
UI for the customer.
So as they've gone
through our portal,
it wasn't loaded until
they went to that area.
So that means a
customer can provision
for many, many different
views within our portal,
but we're not going to
download that into the browser,
and during the time of having
that memory consumption,
until the user wants
to go to that area.
So what does this
look like after it's
gone through the Dart
to JS compile step?
Well, on the left side, you
see without deferred loading.
You have one, monolithic,
huge JavaScript file.
That means that every component
that has been developed
by our teams is in one file.
And so, at the beginning of the
portal loading for a customer
to be one download time, there
is a little spinner that shows.
And they're waiting.
They're like, hey--
can this portal load?
No.
We want to keep it small.
So on the right
side, you see it's
broken up into many, many,
many different part files.
Those are different part files
from the deferred loading
as we import these in.
So this means those aren't going
to be loaded into the browser
until the user
navigates to them.
So Tom Smith has been with
us since our legacy time.
And he's just stating,
here, how great
it's been to leverage the
portal components that we
developed within our portal,
taking advantage of Angular.
And it's made it
easier for our teams
to work independently, and
come up to speed quickly,
and know that things
are going to work
within our portal framework.
So now that the teams
have this base component,
what about the UI components
that they need to use?
I mean, they had
the base component,
but they still need to
build out the HTML that's
going to render to our users.
Well, we have taken advantage
of Angular Components,
and built out our
own core package.
It's called UI Angular.
It houses all of our components.
We've extended off of
Angular Components,
because it's very
easy to take advantage
of different
utilities they have.
And also, extending off
of just base components,
to adding more functionality
that we needed proprietary
to Trustwave.
Also, we have our own
unique style at Trustwave.
And Angular Components is built
off the wonderful material
design, but we have our own
unique style at Trustwave.
So it's been really easy
for us to put our own styles
on these components, as well.
So if you look on
the right side,
this is just our
demo project, that we
have internal at our company,
that's just running through all
the components that we
have leveraged and taken
advantage of.
And this is adding
our own styles
on top of Angular Components,
and some of our own custom
built components, as well.
But what if, in
your company, there
is already a JavaScript
library you have,
because you're converting
over from JavaScript to Dart?
Or there's a library
out there that you
want to take advantage of,
that's not already been ported
over to Dart or AngularDart?
Well, don't worry-- you
can still take advantage
of JavaScript Interop.
So you can use
JavaScript Interop,
build your own AngularDart
wrapper around it,
using that facade
that you built out,
and take advantage of
that JavaScript library.
So we've done this for
two of our components
for charting and for
our richtext editor.
And this is our portal live in
production, on the right side,
there-- an animated
GIF that we built.
And that's showing our
main dashboard views,
taking advantage of High Charts
through JavaScript Interop.
But also, we were looking
for, at the beginning--
we were saying we want the
Tools-IDE IDE integration.
Well, you get, now, with the
Dart plug-in, within IntelliJ.
And we take
advantage of IntelliJ
because we're also a
Java company, as well,
for our back end services.
So now our developers
can work within one IDE,
within IntelliJ, on both
Dart and on our Java side.
We get the code analysis,
the code completion,
the refactoring.
I wasn't able to build a real
complicated GIF, on this side,
because recording myself coding
just didn't work very well.
But this is the
Dart reformatting
that takes place--
the Dart formatter.
And I have to say, I
love the Dart formatter.
Coming from the Java side, and
all the battles and arguments
over formatting, and
going back and forth,
it's really nice that Dart comes
out with just one formatter.
And you can tell
the teams, there's
formatting already within.
Stick with it.
We're not going to
come up with our own.
[APPLAUSE]
Now the teams have built out
all these different packages.
And we talked about,
earlier-- it's
like, we need some sort
of dependency management
to bring this all together.
Well, this really sold us
on using Dart, as well.
We have our own
internal pub server,
that we publish all the
core packages up to,
that the teams can
take advantage of.
And they also publish
their views up,
so we can bring it into
the main build, that we're
going to talk about later on.
So we've fallen in love
with the semantic versioning
that takes place, that Kevin
was talking about, earlier.
We use the current
syntax on it, and we
avoid a lot of breaking changes
and conflicts that come in.
So on this slide, here, is
just an example of pubspec yaml
that shows the URLs of
our internal pub server
that we're taking advantage of
to bring in some of our core
packages to one of our component
libraries that we build out.
Now we need to bring
it all together.
OK?
The teams have worked
on their views,
and we need to bring it
in to one, main build.
So on the right side is our main
pubspec yaml that's in our main
build.
I think it's about
35-plus packages
that we pull in from our
main internal pub server,
into one build.
So our teams can
work independently.
They can publish
off their packages,
and know, when we
build this off,
we pulled in with the
semantic versioning,
and make sure we pull in the
proper version from our teams.
This avoids breaking
changes, because we
make sure we handle the
versioning correctly.
And if there is a
breaking change that
comes from one of
our core components,
we make sure we notify
our teams, at that point.
But we also need to make sure
we have automated builds.
We had this in the
past, and we wanted
to make sure we could do
this with Dart, as well.
So we used Jenkins as our
continuous integration
build server.
And we have built off
a process within there
that runs two to
three times a day
on the main portal
framework builds,
so our teams can make sure
they deploy their packages,
and it will be brought in and
go off to our test networks.
So on the right
shows our main build.
And this is going through,
at first, a pub upgrade,
to bring in the new packages.
Does a pub build.
After that point, it goes
ahead and TAR's up the entire
build, sends it off to
our internal Nexus server,
and then our dev op teams
pick it off from there,
and deploy it off into
our test networks.
So really, we're
hands-off, at this point.
So our teams can
work independent
of the portal
framework, and they
can rely on knowing that
this is going to go out
into the test networks.
On top of that, we
added some traceability
into this automated build.
In the backing HTML, we put
in when the deploy date was,
what version went out, so that
our development teams can say,
hey, did I make it
into that deploy?
We also put out-- in only
our test network deploys--
the pubspec lockfile.
So they can look at that,
out there, and say, oh man--
I didn't make it.
I missed it this window,
but I know its going
to be in the next window,
my newest version.
So at Trustwave,
we are extremely
happy with our implementation
of AngularDart and Dart.
We've been internal
at the company
for about a year and a half
internally, using our portal.
We went beta at the
end of last year.
And I'm happy to announce,
this quarter one,
we have gone GA in
front of our customers.
It's worked wonderful for us.
[APPLAUSE]
And we're looking forward to
coming up, soon, with Dart 2,
and also Angular 5.
The Dart dev compiler,
we want to start
using to get out of using Dart,
even going straight into Chrome
with the Dart dev compiler.
And this quarter, we're starting
to develop our mobile solution
within Flutter.
So we're going to take
advantage of our middle layer,
our business layer.
We have core packages
to take advantage
of those core services
on the back end,
and just focus on the UI
for our mobile solution.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]